okay so today we're gonna be talking
about units
and in particular the weirdest
units the weird and wonderful ones i'm
gonna limit myself to the ones that are
actually used in physics literature
today because otherwise we'd be here all
day talking about pirate ninjas on mars
and measuring bridges in smooths so this
is going to be from my own experiences
in research a little bit of research
i've done and then also just talking to
people on twitter units are important we
should care about units there was 125
million dollar unit error in the mars
climate orbiter in 1999. basically u.s
jpl were expecting the units of thrust
in newtons per second normal si unit of
thrust whereas lockheed martin gave it
to them in pound-force per second
satellite entered mars orbit to shallow
and it exploded in the atmosphere and
everyone's work was lost people should
care about units always write the units
so the one i want to start with is the
one that when i was learning physics i
thought was the weirdest it is a parsec
so a lot of people might be familiar
with the parsec there's that famous line
in star wars the millennium falcon made
the kessel run in 12 parsecs which makes
people think that it's a time but it's
not it's a distance the way that it is
affined is actually in terms of an angle
it's really quite strange so it's all to
do with this thing called parallax the
name parsec comes from a portmanteau of
parallax an arc second which is an angle
parsec everybody probably at some point
has done this where they put their
finger up in front of their face and
then like closing one eye and then
opened it so like oh look my finger's on
the left-hand side of your face brady
and oh now it's on the right hand side
of your face you're moving right hand
side i'm not moving my finger yeah you
are i'm not sorry okay should i do it
again i don't mind i'm just sure i'm
going to show it back to you
i wasn't trying to move it okay left
right left right
skill up so stupid
um and so basically what's happening
there is that the foreground object is
moving with respect to the background
object brady uh with respect to like
what angle i am viewing my finger at and
if i move my finger away from my face
and close to two it moves us a smaller
angle and a bigger angle so same thing
happens with stars so foreground stars
moving with respect to sort of the
background stars or the constellations
so in terms of like where the earth is
in in winter my left eye and where the
earth is in summer my right eye sees a
star move
a certain angle with respect to the
background stars and you work out that
that angle actually corresponds to a
distance you use trigonometry and the
distance from the earth the sun so it
turns out that a parsec is about 3 times
10 to the 16 meters a parsec is 30 peta
meters we don't go around saying things
like you know that the sun is 5 micro
parsecs away it's definitely only used
for distances outside the solar system
well the cool thing is it scales really
well so nearby stars are like 10 to 100s
of parsecs galaxies are killer parsecs
across galaxies are separated by
megaparsecs and then the universe itself
is
gigaparsex across so this comes from the
idea of a hubble length you know what's
the distance to the furthest object that
we can observe and that's about 4.5
gigapass x and that's also similar to
the hubble time as well which is our
best estimate for the age of the
universe 14 giga years billions of years
as gig years so it feels really weird to
me to talk about distances in terms of
angle shifts why wouldn't you just
calculate the distance and i had a
little put down from someone on twitter
for my millennial ways and they said to
me folks wouldn't think parsec was so
weird if their professional career
extended back to the time when
electronic calculators were rarities
owned by university departments so
bill keel professional astronomer in
alabama put me in my place an electron
vault it's not a voltage
no do you know what it is instead it's
like i think it's energy isn't it it is
yeah so it's not a voltage it's an
energy
of an electron basically so it's the
energy that an electron gains
moving through a voltage of one volt so
obviously electricity comes from the
movement of particles with charges and
protons and electrons protons tend to be
locked into atoms so it's the electrons
that move so it makes a lot of sense
when you think about it like that but
the reason that i think it's weird is
that it's not a defined unit it's an
empirical unit it comes from measurement
so to actually refer to an electron
vault in an experiment you have to
actually measure what the energy gained
by the electron is over one volts
uh because it's not necessarily like
defined like say the speed of light is
defined uh it's a measurement unit and
and so i think that's kind of weird how
it becomes the sort of like
self-referential kind of unit so if you
do measure an electron volt it comes out
at 1.6 times 10 to the minus 19 joules
or 16 atto joules if you prefer so
atomic physics nuclear physics particle
physics they all deal with the tiny
things in our universe and so these kind
of energies are appropriate for those
fields cool thing is though it's not
often used as energy unit it's used as a
mass unit
yeah so if we think about what einstein
told us e equals m c squared energy and
mass or equivalent once we've measured
how much energy an electron has in this
one volts we then can know its mass if
we divide it by c squared so a lot of
times that you see electron volt it's
actually quoting the mass of these tiny
tiny particles uh instead you just have
to remember that there's this divided by
c squared unit that's there as well that
you have to not forget an electron
0.511 mega electron volts per c squared
and that might sound really strange but
like most undergrad physicists will
probably know that off the top of the
head
in mega electron volts for c squared
which is kind of cool right the higgs
boson that's
125 giga electron volts for c squared
and so again this idea of like the the
prefix of the units gives you an idea of
how much bigger in terms of an electron
the higgs boson really is it's one of
the most massive particles we know so
it's an energy but sometimes used as a
mass
so brady have you ever heard of snoopy
yeah he's my mic he's snoopy he's my
favorite rapper
it's not like snoopy's cousin no he's a
rapper
snoopy so i think this is one of my
favorites snoopy it stands for
supernova unit in the b band so
basically what it is is the number of
supernova
per century
per 10 to the power of 10 solar
luminosities in the b band
yeah
um basically what it boils down to is
number of supernova per century per
galaxy because galaxies are about sort
of 10 billion solar luminosities each
ish it's about two to three for the
milky way so i mean it's probably the
smallest number astronomy has so you've
got to give us that we live in a two to
three snoopy galaxy exactly two to three
snoopys you can do this in any
astronomical wave band um so you know
this is the range of wavelengths that
you look at to tell what amount of light
that you're getting in optical infrared
so that can be u b v r i g z y j h k l m
and q
so you can have snoovy
snook a
snug
and this one snoozies snoozies yeah you
could have snoozies as well i wonder
whether it'd be like five snoozies
rather than like two to three snoopy's
for the milky way i don't know but i
just love the idea that like
professional supernova astronomers going
around going oh yeah that one's like
three snoopys
so
i guess that one gets in there for the
names just too much fun okay so let's uh
break this down kerma for kinetic energy
released per unit mass do you think
about like a radioactive atom how much
kinetic energy it releases air kerma is
you know how much kinetic energy is
released per unit mass into a unit mass
of air so how much energy the air then
absorbs air kermit strength is then you
know how much energy is deposited into
the air at a distance away from the
radioactive source squared okay
so uh air kerma is obviously this energy
so that's measured in just joules per
kilogram but then people refer to that
as a gray instead which is shortened
capital gy not to be confused with a gig
year which is capital gyr and so that's
a gray and then you've got that um in
terms of you know the rate so it's per
hour as well but it's you know air coma
strength so it's this distance away so
it's the grays per hour per meter
squared
okay and they decided that was too
complicated of a unit to to work in and
so they gave it a new name do you want
to know what they called this unit
unit
they called it unit
and it has a just a capital u
it's just it's oh my god it's so
ridiculous that they just called it unit
like how lazy can you be
so one or arrogant yeah hurricane yeah
it's just this is the defining unit one
u one unit
is uh a micro grey per meter squared per
hour
an erg
it's not like an unsure egg it's
actually a unit of energy so most of the
units that we come across every day are
you know like meters seconds kilograms
everything like that there are a part of
a unit system that's actually defined
it's called the s-i
units basically the defined system but
and so in the s-i units your standard
unit of energy is joules people are
quite familiar with that instead you can
work in a completely different system of
units which is called cgs or centimeters
grams per second okay and that's your
base system that all your units are
built of and the base uh energy unit in
that system is ergs okay this might
sound a little bit weird to people but
back at the turn of like sort of the
century of the 1800s to 1900s this was
the preferred system of units maxwell
was a big fan of working in cgs and he
wanted that to become like adopted
across all fields this is one of these
sort of historical units that was was in
use then in in a lot of areas of physics
because you know centimeters grams
second when you're thinking about early
physics in like labs those are the kind
of scales that you're working with right
you're working with grams of substance
across centimeters in terms of seconds
so it made total sense thing is because
it's tradition there are some fields
that still use it problem is fields that
still use this it's astronomy where
they're then quoting energies released
from black holes at like 10 to the 44
eggs per second and energy released from
supernova of 10 to the 51 eggs it just
it's such a ridiculous unit to now work
in so if you think about energy we think
about maybe calories as well one calorie
is 41 giga eggs so that'll give you an
idea of how small an egg is and so this
is why using it in astronomy is
ridiculous right so much so that um
supernova scientists again these pesky
supernova scientists just inventing
units they decided that most supernovae
are about 10 to the 51 eggs so they
invented a new unit which is a foe which
comes from 10 to the 51 eggs so a foe is
10 to the 51 irks and so they'll go
around saying oh yeah that supernova
went off with like two foe
or like 3.24
you look so gangster
the only time i've ever looked gangster
info
that's supernova
we're back at astronomy and i have to
say this one probably got the most hate
on twitter like there are so many
frustrated astronomers out there that
have to use this unit and they just hate
it the jamski and it's used a lot in
radio astronomy so it's all about the
flux density that you have from a radio
source how much energy you're actually
getting from that radio source per sort
of unit angle on the sky so a jansky is
defined as 10 to the minus 26 watts per
square meter per hertz so you're working
in hertz as well which is the frequency
of radiation you're out the frequency of
the radiation you want to know in terms
of like per meter squared because that's
your collecting area of your actual sort
of ccd as well and then your watts is
obviously the amount of energy that
you're actually getting from it but
you've also had to integrate over the
angle that you were on in the sky as
well and the way that the chansky is
defined is that you have to integrate
over a unit angle which is called the
steradian so a stair radian is basically
just a square radian just a weird word
for it so you have to integrate over
square radians on the sky as well so
it's just this horrendous
unit especially if you've never come
across it before so i kind of feel like
it's a little bit of a barrier to entry
for a lot of students that come to radio
astronomy as well in the fact that it's
such a weird unit and also just
conversion from
that unit to units that people are used
to working with in like optical studies
instead like if you want to do like a
comparative you know i have my source
and i've seen it in the optical but now
how much energy does it have in the
radio and how does that compare you
obviously have to convert those units to
the same unit to be able to compare them
which brings me on to my next unit which
is related which is called the nano
maggie i just think of like tiny maggie
simpson
the nano maggie which is about 3.6 times
10 to the minus six janski's or 3.6
microgame skis
is what the nanomagi is defined as and
it comes from sort of your zero point in
the magnitude system that you're working
with this magnitude is like brightness
system in astronomy and it's just this
huge mess still
so
it's on my list because it's caused
astronomers so much frustration over the
years so this is a paper from
astronomers again
and they're studying um
molecular cloud densities so the clouds
that are going to form stars the gas
that's all going to condense to form
stars they're looking at how dense they
are in the universe and what the
pressure is in these clouds as well
that's going to squish them together the
sentence is moreover some of the highest
column density clumps would require
enormous confining pressures of roughly
a thousand to a billion kelvin per
centimeter cubed
so that was a pressure
in kelvins per centimeter cubed kelvin a
unit of temperature and centimeter cubed
a unit of volume
so they're quoting pressures in
temperatures per volume most of the time
pressures are done in atmospheres or
bars as well but here they're doing it
in kelvin per cubed which probably
doesn't make any sense until you think
about the context so in space the gases
that you're dealing with the gases that
you're modeling here they're very low
density there's barely any interactions
you know there's no collisions and so
basically what we call that is an ideal
gas so we might remember that from high
school ideal gases okay that can be
always models like ideal gas and so that
means that we can apply the ideal gas
law which people might remember pv
equals nrt you put it on the screen p
being the pressure b being the volume n
is the number of moles of an element r
being a constant and then t being the
temperature astronomers change this so
that they're working in the number of
actual atoms they've got because they
can kind of estimate the number atom
because it's such low densities they
rearrange it so that it's p equals
number of atoms divided by the volume
times by the boltzmann constant times
temperature and they basically just say
drop the bottom constant and then they
say the pressure is therefore the
temperature over the volume
and so basically everybody knows that
when they quote these numbers of like a
thousand to a billion kelvin per
centimeter cubed that there's some
boltzmann constant in there that they
haven't taken into account um but they
don't say it it's just that everybody
knows
that it's there which i think is just
really lazy and also they haven't dubbed
this unit i feel like this unit should
be dubbed like the lazy or something
like it it's just they need to give it a
name if they're gonna keep using it
because it's really strange and it would
really confuse people especially people
like new to the field that have never
even come across this before last but
not least is a barn
have you heard of barn before
like barn conversions or like sheds and
stuff okay
so a barn
is used in particle physics all the time
it's a cross-sectional area of a
particle okay so it's about 100
femtometers squared it's defined as so
that's 10 to the minus 28 meters squared
and it's about the cross-sectional area
of a uranium nucleus the reason it's
called a barn it comes from the u.s
expression couldn't hit the broad side
of a barn which means that your aim is
terrible basically so obviously the idea
of particle physics is you're trying to
get two particle beams to collide and
your aim needs to be good so you need to
be able to hit a barn and so they they
talk about you know one barn
cross-sectional area or we know we've
got to hit that target within like point
five bahn i presume i
can presume that's what like the control
centers of these particle physics
experiments are like you need more bands
the cross-sectional area of a particle
you know you've obviously got something
tiny times by something tiny obviously
even smaller so that's why they needed a
new unit i'll give them that it's not an
si unit necessarily but it is recognized
by them as a unit because it's used so
much in the field as well similar to
ajansky actually there's also
technically the outhouse which is a
micro barn
and the shed which is a yocto barn the
thing that i love about barns is that
you basically have a tiny
area okay
and what about if we combined a tiny
area with a very large distance
so if you remember we had a very large
distance at the beginning we had parsecs
and we were talking about the hubble
distance being like 4.5 gigaparsec okay
and if we combine a very small area
and a very large distance
we get a volume
okay but very very tiny area and very
very large distance gives you a volume
that's actually quite appreciable to
like everyday volumes combine a barn and
a mega parsec you get a barn mega parsec
which is about the size of a teaspoon
yeah which i really really like remember
our hubble length before was 4.5 giga
parsecs so you can have a hubble barn
which again is a volume and it's about
13 liters
so you could talk about like filling up
your car with like cobble barns if you
wanted to like my car gets so many
hubble barns miles per hubble barn
which i think is really really nice so
that got me thinking
whether we could use these crazy units
in something more every day
uh perhaps like a cake recipe
and perhaps we could have a
physics-inspired cake recipe
all in crazy units yeah yeah yeah okay i
actually got a cake recipe you made one
i actually well i i i acquired a cake
recipe yeah from maryberry obviously
yeah uh and i've rewritten her cake
recipe yeah to be physics go on yeah i
feel like this should be read in like my
most bbc rp accent what do you think
yeah yeah yeah okay
okay
preheat the oven to give an output flux
density in the infrared regime of seven
yocto nanomaggies
then make sure to grease and line two
6.5 atto parsec sandwich tins
break four eggs that's eggs not eggs
into a large mixing bowl then mix in
126 yota electron volts per speed of
light squared of both sugar and flour
with two barn mega parsecs of baking
powder and 0.006 hubble barns of butter
divide the mixture evenly between the
two tins and bake the cakes on the
middle shelf of the oven for three femto
hubble times
sandwich together with jam once cool and
sprinkle over some caster sugar for
decoration and there you have it a
physics-inspired victoria sponge cake
[Music]
you